uh interesting weekend as it relates to
this percolating sense that
the falcons
want
to trade julio jones can they trade him
is really the question that still
lingers it was four weeks ago today the
monday of draft week and it was no
accident that three different reporters
all had the same scoop at about the same
time that the falcons are looking to
trade julio jones they deliberately got
it out there they spread the word they
wanted going into the draft anyone
looking for a receiver to know if you
don't get that guy you covet we got
somebody that you may be interested in
if you simply want to take on a 15.3
million dollar salary guaranteed for
skill injury and cap in 2021 and they've
made it clear that they want a second
round pick the same round they got a
pick for when they gave muhammad sunu to
the patriots in 2019 but it's all about
unloading that salary and creating cap
space as of june 2 when they can
reduce the acceleration that otherwise
would hit the cap they can't do it
pre-june 1 they can do it as of june 2.
we're just a week away from that
happening but a deal can be tentatively
agreed to between now and then chris i
still have yet to hear anything see
anything read anything divine anything
that would suggest there's a trade
partner okay okay good for julio jones
good of you i'm glad to hear you say
that i'm not gonna lie like i was a
little stressed this morning
driving into the office going like i
don't really have any feel for anybody
that's really interested in them right
now i don't not like legitimately i i
really was i was a little so i'm glad to
hear you say that that you haven't
really heard anything solid along those
lines either i haven't as well and you
know that that's where i'm fascinated by
this whole topic with julio jones just
because you know there's a lot of moving
parts to it you know he is the ultimate
boom or bust i think
type of trade uh you know
asset player whatever yeah i do think
that you know he's still got some
mileage left and we see last year there
was a few games where he looks special
and all those type of things but mike
you and i both know we've talked about
this a lot throughout the years i mean
julio jones is a little dangerous too at
this point of his career it has been a
lot of wear and tear and you and i both
know that he doesn't practice much it's
load management to the finest as far as
nfl wide receivers are concerned and not
that he's like oh i'm just taking it off
but i think he's got issues he's
managing within his body to be able to
play every sunday like we talked about a
little last week so that's where
you know yeah good player whoa a lot of
money
team he's on right now doesn't really
need him anymore you know who out there
is going to be really desperate for a
guy with all of those type of things
it's going to take a special type of
investigation to feel comfortable with
with the player there that's where uh
it's going to be interesting to see what
atlanta could get for it
well the folks at points bet know
something they know enough to set odds
for the next destination of julio jones
and look
what teams at the very top the san
francisco 49ers at plus 450 colts and
the chargers not far behind a plus 475.
do you think that the
the 49ers would
would make a move i i know that it's
easy to connect dots
in atlanta the year that the falcons
almost won a super bowl and julio jones
was still smack dab in the middle of his
prime but that was five years ago
exactly would he would would julio jones
of today make a difference for a 49ers
offense that you know beyond the
quarterback question
is really good fairly loaded yeah it's
loaded right you know loaded mike and i
was surprised to see this and again i i
have no inside information here
i don't know what the 49ers maybe they
do like julio jones i don't know i
really have no clue
i was shocked i think phillip may know
since philip has your phone he might
maybe he's been texting kyle maybe he
knows maybe you let him know maybe
that's where i didn't figure out it was
trey lance maybe philip knew all along
and that's where you go
but like i was surprised to see the
49ers on the top of that list you know
for for like you said it's a talented
offense they got two young receivers
that i would be if i'm kyle shanahan i'm
reluctant to take off the field i mean
it's the top of the fir second round
debo samuel wide receiver who's very
talented brandon ayuk first round wide
receiver you know and the 49ers are a
team mike too that they're not a big
three wide receiver on the field type of
offense shanahan likes his tight end and
his fullback and to be in that 21
personnel that we talk about so much so
that's where i didn't i was shocked to
see that is what i'm saying i didn't
think that made sense and i don't see
that happening with the 49ers
and again there's been there's been
nothing linking julio jones to anyone
and and if the falcons were getting any
calls from any team i guarantee you
it would make its way
out into the media some way somehow
except for one team because bill
belichick has managed to convince anyone
and everyone that if anything ever comes
out about any discussions that we've had
with you about any of our players or
your players or anything that possibly
could be transacted we pull the plug
immediately and we mean it that's why
agents don't talk teams don't talk you
never know what bill belichick's up to
however yeah however there was a report
from mike giardi of nfl media over the
weekend the patriots have had internal
discussions about jones she already
followed it up with i don't know how
serious they were well
i mean all due respect why wouldn't they
have internal discussions if we don't at
a minimum you're gonna you're gonna at
some point you know you're drinking a
cup of coffee and eating a doughnut hey
why julio jones are really trying to
move him yeah what do you think well
next i mean that's internal discussions
it could be it could be they brought it
up and shut it down or it could be all
the way up to they're plotting to make a
move as of june 2 to go try to get him
well anytime i hear like the patriots
when i i have a player that yes is
rumored to be on the market and all
those things and then you don't hear
about teams substantially in the
argument and all of a sudden the
patriots come out of nowhere i won't lie
and i'm not disputing reporting or
anything like that but i always think oh
that might be propaganda because you
know that's the move right in the recent
nfl tell the world that the patriots are
interested in my player and now
they think that you know the other 31
teams are like the patriots we got oh
yeah bill bill's on it uh oh he knows
something we don't we better get
interested right i mean for new england
i'd be like no you don't need julio
jones either you have a ton of offense
and these are the guys that have blown
up in their face i mean aka mohammed
sunu
you know
aging veterans where belichick might
have had like an uh
affinity am i saying that right for
right yes good but now he's like he's
old and it's it's dangerous and he's
breaking down and that to me is like
this would be the the ultimate like new
england ooh i don't know if this is
going to work type moves so i don't know
if i buy that
randy moss was 30 his first year with
the patriots 30 yeah just second that
worked i know but that worked
and it was perceived it was perceived
that he was washed up at 30. that that
now to a trained eye it's just randy
moss didn't care his second year with
the raiders it was a waste of his time
exactly he wasn't trying right he shut
it down right and the patriots secretly
i don't know how secret it was i
remember al davis suggesting there was
some sort of collusion between mike
lombardi and bill belichick but they
knew he could still run they did the
deal for a fourth round pick and it
worked out now
the patriots are the ones who gave up
the second round pick from muhammad
saneu so maybe the falcons think they
are the i know the ones that that maybe
will overpay for this guy but the key is
going to be
the salary
what's the salary right
what how much are you going to take on
and how much will the falcons pay the
falcons are not going to get off the
hook paying zero they're going to have
to pay some of it especially if they
want a second round pick how much are
they going to have to pay to make it
work and here's the other side of it too
thomas dimitrov who was the gm yeah the
falcons right can now tell bill exactly
what's up with julio jones that's true
everything that julio jones has done
physically all the stuff that went on
three years ago when julio jones was
gonna hold out and insisted on getting
a contract that made him the highest
paid receiver in football that contract
that's weighing the falcons cap down now
dimitrov can now be completely and
totally transparent and
uh you know if belichick makes a move
then that means there's still plenty of
gas in the tank and there's reason to
think that it's a worthwhile trade if
the patriots don't
make the move then you know at a minimum
he's going to talk to dimitrov because
demitrov has no reason to not talk to
believe at this point he's not in the in
the trust tree anymore with the falcons
but he sure knows a lot from the time
that he was no i know yes and you know
again julio jones could he help out the
new england patriots
sure
but to the way that we would envision it
and him being like a big 1500 yard type
receiver and being a staple in the
offense i just don't see that happening
with the way the patriots are built
right now and cam newton at quarterback
and everything like that and you've got
a quarterback that's going to take over
you know in the future and mac jones and
what are you gonna do trade away future
assets to hinder his ability to develop
and all those things what for one two
years maybe with julio jones that's
where it doesn't make sense to me it's
going to be
a special team who really feels like hey
we're we're truly maybe a one guy away
or we're desperate at this position or
something like that that type of player
what you think new england is that what
what do you say no no no no what you're
you're leading me down a path i know it
went down on friday with shereen
williams when you were in your hammock
right with your mismatched legs and
and and uh neck tan uh the green bay
packers yes no doubt that's a team that
certainly jumps out to you when you kind
of lay it out there where you go wait
everything's kind of good they got a lot
of things to like on the roster as we've
seen they missed like an explosive part
of the element of their offense he could
maybe bring that you know that is but
again i think it's the big thing too is
like these teams are going to have to do
some i don't want to say collusion
are there investigations
into
the status of julio jones body that is
going to be the big thing to me almost
like that's always the rumors i heard
exactly what you're talking about with
the raiders and the patriots and the
randy moss thing i mean the rumor in the
nfl was that the patriots followed him
for a period of time when he was in
miami and had people watching him work
out to know that he was actually healthy
and those type of things so that's the
kind of info you got to dig up on julio
because yeah you don't want to trade
away
you know low round picks or yeah
high round picks and give substantial
money to a guy who what all of a sudden
might be on the field eight nine games
this year that's where it's scary mike
and here's like another thing mike too
like that it's
if you're if you're atlanta
you can't just trade julio jones away
for a two can you like you can't just do
a two yes that's yes that's what they
want i wanted two they don't want
anything more than that they're gonna
just settle with a two i to me that's
not necessarily the best look either i
mean the fact that they got mohamed sanu
away for two and now you're gonna give
julio jones away that's just right but
but but
you you're you're you're
only getting a two because they're
taking the 2.3 million off your books
yes and i don't know that they get both
i don't know that you can pull that off
no you're right i think to get the two
you got to pay
5 million maybe i don't know
and if you if you're only going to pay
a million or two or nothing you're gonna
get a lot less than a two it did they go
hand in hand yeah definitely but the
packers to me are fascinating because if
the front office truly wants to rebuild
the obliterated bridge with aaron
rodgers if you really want to work
something out you go to aaron rodgers
with a spreadsheet with some sort of a
document with something
to show him here's the contract that we
propose for you here's how you're going
to create some cap space through it but
it's also going to tie us to you and you
to us for multiple years oh we're going
to put a no trade clause in there as
well you're going to have a lot of money
there's going to be guarantee it's going
to be a big cap number next year we
can't just walk away we can't rip it up
we can't trade you you will be our guy
and with the cap money that we create
this year along with restructuring let's
say devonte adams contract because he's
one of the guys with an eight-figure
salary that could create some cap space
for the packers we're gonna go get julio
jones so you're gonna have devante adams
you're gonna have julio jones let's go
let's do this and and
i don't know that that would fix things
at this point but if the packers really
wanted to try to fix it that would seem
like the kind of gesture that
that aaron rodgers would at least pay
some attention i i would agree with that
yeah you could really maybe you know
kill you know uh what is it one bird
with two stones
two birds with one stone
no no it's too late you took your hand
off it right yep i got it wrong you're
right it's a monday morning i'm foggy so
yes but yeah you could do both there
like improve your team make it explosive
maybe have a guy make a play in an nfc
championship game other than aaron
rodgers having to be perfect and dissect
everything and every perfect throw
and every perfect decision like you know
it's not against the rules for one of
those guys to break a tackle and run for
50 yards like the other teams do against
them i mean it's not so yeah you could
do that and help your team out and also
like you're saying
kill that other bird because hey here's
a guy for you aaron rodgers we're still
trying to support you i mean agreed mike
it's the first team that came to my mind
too you know that i mean come on that's
my guy up there i'd like to see some
weapons around him
yeah i don't know that the packers
really care at this point the packers as
far as i can tell continue to be
in that posture of play for us or play
for no one by the way otas start today i
doubt that aaron rodgers will be there
he's got a 500 000 workout bonus issue
they worked out something with the
packers players where they could put in
their time phase one and phase two on
their own they didn't have to be there
to get credit toward their workout bonus
but they got to be there for phase three
to get credit toward the workout bonus
and it's usually a high percentage like
90 or more that you have to participate
in to earn that bonus so
aaron rodgers is going to either going
to be there this week or isn't and i
don't think it's going to be a big story
one way or the other because i don't
expect him to be there the mandatory
mini camp is what's gonna matter and
rogers is on
espn tonight kenny mayne's last show
we'll see
we'll we'll see what rogers delves into
uh i i how can you have him on
and and not get into
yeah i would think so so maybe we'll
find something out tonight deandre
hopkins at one point in the past few
days
that he would restructure his contract
for julio jones and then he deleted it
and maybe he deleted it because someone
said to him there's really nothing you
can do exactly your salary is 4.75
million it's not like it's going to
create that much cap space they have
other guys on the team like a chandler
jones where they could do he and even
though jones is in the last year of his
contract you could take that salary add
some dummy years turn it into a signing
bonus create some cap space that way and
they're pressed up against the cap yeah
packers they'd have to create some cap
space but there's not much deandre
hopkins can do on the other side of it
too i think at some point who knows why
he deleted it but you got other
teammates you got that's what it is
exactly
more right like those guys are going to
be like what the hell who are we
that's it i i would mike you're i think
that's spot on that's what kind of
jumped out to me throughout the whole
thing it's like he came to the
realization like damn we got a lot of
good receivers like kind of i'm kind of
being disrespectful here by adding this
guy into the group here and we got some
guys that i would bet you some of the
people and someone in the organization
maybe even reached out to him to like
hey we're excited about this group we
got we're we're good like you know aj's
here he's already filled that role that
julio would do so we don't need another
guy to be like that i mean what two like
risky veteran type receivers why so they
can both be like riding bikes on the
sidelines and you know that doesn't make
sense to me there i will say this with
arizona i mean uh on the fact of julio
and teams that at least makes sense a
little to me to a degree is arthur
smith's old team like with the tennessee
titans i've i know derek henry put
something on social media and that was
one when he said it or it just popped
into my brain where i was like
you know they have a need they
definitely do he would fit it across the
you know the field from aj brown they're
gonna run the ball play action pass let
him work down the field do those type of
things and with no corey davis or
anybody like that there is no real
big time number two there or one you
know uh yeah number two in tennessee
right now so that would make sense
derek henry's tweet titan tf up
that that's all
it doesn't take a genius to figure out
what he's really saying there but he
wants julio jones and there was a video
of the two of them working out as well
not that that means anything be like oh
look at this googly eye emoji
julio jones and derek henry working out
so what derek henry's not the gm of the
team it means nothing yeah two guys on
the same team are working out together
you know what it means it means it's
late may and there isn't much else to
talk about and i got no problem with
that i understand the business side of
it but it means nothing until the titans
look around
the issue and consider doing it and hey
it
that that is a spot where he could make
a difference if you can make it work
from a cap standpoint he could make a
difference for that titan's team yeah i
i do think so you know yes it's it's a
it's an offense that fits the player he
is
you know and i think yeah you play
action pass you let him work down field
he can run post corners and deep outs
and posts and go routes and all those
type of things tana hill's a great down
the field one-on-one type thrower you
know him and aj brown they're both
physical specimens you wouldn't be able
to really pin either guy to like one
specific part of the offense they could
both go over the middle and be physical
they could both beat you deep do those
type of things that that made sense mike
and honestly another team in the afc
south the indianapolis colts is the
other team to me that makes a lot of
sense just from the fact of like yeah
they're in the super bowl one of the
things that's hurt them a little the
last few years paris campbell being
heard t-y hilton a little older and
banged up and things like that maybe
this just gives you another embody a
body insurance another weapon just in
case some of those guys do get banged up
during the year that you got a tip top
offense around carson wentz i mean
they're a team that's right now i mean
got everything you need maybe just
looking for a little cream on the on the
top there to just make it a little bit
better
if this is about dumping salary
primarily then the falcons i think will
take whatever they can get as of june 2
or beyond and wipe that money off the
books and have that cash and cap space
to spend on other players if this is
about maximizing draft capital chris
their
only option may be yeah keep leo jones
around
wait for the season to flesh itself out
let other teams see he still got it
right and then if the falcons aren't
contending
by the time the trade deadline rolls
around
then maybe one of these other teams out
there feeling like he's the missing
piece will will over play like the
patriots did for muhammad sununu like
the 49ers did for emmanuel sanders when
they gave up a third round pick and say
okay fine he's healthy he's having a
good year the falcons are struggling now
if he's healthy and having a good year
maybe the falcons won't be struggling
and they won't want to give him up but
they may have to play this out and they
may have to get into the season if this
is about getting the highest possible
draft pick but if this is about just
getting rid of 15.3 million
then
bye bye next week and make us an offer
what are you gonna offer us third round
pick fourth round pick fifth round pick
whatever as long as you're taking the
15.3 off our books because that money is
guaranteed for skill injury and cap they
can't just cut it right yeah it's uh
i mean 100 you're right they would
maximize their leverage there yeah
there's risk of course yeah like you
said like if he got banged up maybe or
pulled a hamstring when when the trade
you know deadline is around and now he
can't be traded or maybe that you know
those teams we talk about just don't
have that injury but you're right i
think that would be their best chance to
maximize and i do think the question of
like that you bring up whether it's
about
is it about the money and just getting
it out of here or is it do we want to
collect assets are we really trying to
do that aka more like the miami dolphins
the last few years to set up their team
if that's the case i don't know i mean
arthur blank i don't think he's hurting
in the cash department you know it's cap
it's cap yes it's cap it's cap but
either way i mean the more they can
swallow the more they might be able to
get maybe you can get more than just a
second round or this type of the year
if you can kind of find a way to take on
the burden more than than you'd expect
if they're coming to the conclusion that
matt ryan is going to be the guy for the
next few years they need that cap space
even if only to carry it over for next
year when matt ryan's cap number is yeah
so i think it's about the cap space
and i personally think that if they
didn't have the guaranteed salary they
would just cut him if they can't find a
trade partner now from julio jones
perspective last point on this yeah
don't let yourself become juwan james
show up be there for the otas because
that would be if the falcons really are
just looking to dump cap space he
suffers a serious injury away from the
facility hey up your salary is only
guaranteed for skill injury that happens
at work and salary cap injury that
doesn't happen at work you're not
guaranteed for that we're going to cut
you just like the broncos did with juwan
james he's at risk of that he needs to
be in the building
to to avoid that potential outcome and
make sure that 15.3 million remains
fully guaranteed
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports